hi i'm brian and welcome to our session
at google cloud next this session is
going to be about achieving high
resiliency and availability with google
cloud infrastructure i'm joined by my
friend and colleague chris schilling
we're both product managers at google
and are excited to talk to you about
this session
the session today is going to cover a
number of topics first we're going to
talk about why resiliency and high
availability matter in the cloud
a little bit about what google cloud
provides to customers as a foundation of
the platform
some of the things you as a user of
google cloud need to take into account
as you architect your solutions and
applications on google cloud then chris
is going to talk a little bit about
business continuity planning and it's a
good idea for all applications and all
systems and then we'll give you some
links about how to find more information
with this i'd like to turn it over to
chris to get into the content
thanks brian now let's talk about why
resiliency and high availability matter
to technologists building in the cloud
terms like resiliency can be used in a
lot of different contexts nike
infrastructure
we hear the term in the context of
distributed systems
context of
databases in the context of networking
when we think broadly about what defines
resilient infrastructure
anchor are two key components
first off that infrastructure needs to
be able to handle failures without
unexpected data loss
if there is a network partition that
results in the loss of a node for
example resilient distributed database
with many nodes should be able to
recover without a split brain situation
similarly if there is a disk failure in
a brazilian enterprise storage array the
system should have copies of that data
available elsewhere to mitigate against
data loss
so that's the first component of
resiliency failure should not be in data
loss
the second component is that resiliency
means more than one layer of defense
just as infrastructure as multiple
components from software-defined storage
to the relational database to network
and access security the business logic
middle tier
so too this resiliency
resilient infrastructure will have
defense baked into those layers and in
certain layers multiple lines of effects
if resiliency is a fundamentally
defensive concept focused on your data
high availability on the other hand is
about your end user's experience
highly available applications are still
available to the user
even when something goes wrong with the
infrastructure
that means that your users should be
adversely affected when failure occurs
an application can be resilient without
being highly available
work could be highly available without
resiliency
we'd all like to achieve both
and that's why we at google cloud view
these goals as linked
if your goal is high availability for a
global consumer application
you want to ensure that an individual
hardware failure in one of your cloud
regions would not impact your customers
experience
that almost always means thinking about
resiliency because data loss can be
harmful to your customers as well
similarly if your goal is resiliency you
want to make sure that all your
defensive hard work to protect against
data loss to create layers of defense
will also have a direct business impact
ideally because your customers never
notice any change their experience even
when things go wrong
so those are our linguals
both resiliency and high availability
when we break down the requirements for
those like the first one on our list is
infrastructure durability it lines up
more with defensive nature of resiliency
because here we're talking about
providing hardware slas
we're talking about making sure our data
centers are safe
and we're thinking about how we respond
to escalations within our network
a good example of infrastructure
durability is our public durability
service level objective for persistent
disk our block storage offering
for regional balance pd for example
we share that we have better than
99.9999
durability six nines
next up is application availability
that's something that veers toward the
high availability goal because we're
thinking about how to keep a database up
and running for your transactional
applications or how to move traffic to
the right node or even region within a
distributed application
a great product level example is our
high availability configuration for
cloud sql our managed database offering
it lets you set up an architecture
designed to limit user impact the
primary database instant fails
last but not least is business
continuity
we view this as a core component for
both link goals because this is all
about planning checking and double
checking that you have an infrastructure
safety net
that means taking backups
to ensure resiliency
it also means testing your active active
disaster recovery architecture to ensure
high availability for your application
one product that we have in the space is
our multi-region storage which stores
your backup data across multiple google
cloud regions in a given copy
the result is that it's easy to restore
in multiple google cloud regions on that
continent depending on what your
business continuity plan calls for
one other takeaway from all this is
google cloud delivers infrastructure
durability to all our infrastructures or
service customers
this is a default setting for us not an
upcharge or an option
if you want to build a resilient highly
available application we want to take
care of the first step
the next two steps ensuring application
availability
and creating a business continuity plan
of attack
those are equally important
for them we offer our customers tools
and services they can adopt to meet
specific goals
we recognize that some tier one
customer-facing transactional
applications will have requirements
above and beyond an internal sandbox
application a few years a few users and
no customer data for example
so let's talk about durability first
this is a great topic you can solve
because google cloud really shines here
all our customers get the benefit of
infrastructure durability that underpins
some of the world's favorite
applications
like youtube
and that starts with storage for all
types of applications
our block offering persistent disk
our first party file offering file store
in our object storage offering cloud
storage
i'll count some of the world's largest
enterprises as customers and users
regardless of whether you're a startup
or a fortune 100 company you can find
the same public durability information
on our persistent disk offerings on our
website
all that information is available
publicly we recently published a blog
post to help customers further
understand how we approach this
durability and what we do to keep your
infrastructure safe
similarly as we're a service provider
for the infrastructure we have
operational safeguards in place to make
sure you have a trusted platform to
build on
that means having encryption by default
for example so you don't have to worry
about accidental linkage of unencrypted
data
it also means having site reliability
engineering or sre coverage across our
glowing growing global footprint across
all of our services
many of google's sres
have contributed to the open literature
and public practices that helped make
all of us in product engineering
better in our operations
you get the benefit of all this
knowledge
and the benefit of having these sres
available to address service level
issues when you build on google cloud
i'll hand the rest of the slide over to
brian
thanks chris
the other part of infrastructure
durability really comes from our global
data centers and our network our global
data centers are significant we have 27
regions and over 82 zones built out in
many continents in the world and they
offer a tremendous amount of on-demand
capacity and many layers of physical
security in the data centers themselves
of course we've layered on top of this
infrastructure
sophisticated hardware monitoring and
all of these are used to basically offer
the many managed services that are part
of the google cloud network
and of course the network i always like
to tell people the google cloud network
scales and has high availability because
google itself has scale and high
availability almost everybody in the
world has some appreciation for the
scale of google's consumer services you
probably use some of these you know
almost every day
these same pieces of infrastructure in
the same network is used to provide the
capabilities that we offer in the google
cloud platform
and of course we have significant
investments in undersea cabling uh edge
pops or points of presence where are
essentially appearing into the internet
and the network
and of course we have thousands of edge
caches to make the performance of google
services and of course the performance
of many google cloud services incredibly
performant and available the other thing
i like to use as an example is our
networking prowess and the
software-defined networking we have in
google cloud makes it really easy for
you to build on top of this global
infrastructure a specific example of
that is the global vpcs or virtual
private clouds that you can build
they're network constructs that are very
easy to set up and essentially span
google cloud region so you can create
one virtual network that spans region
makes it very easy for you to build
global applications that take advantage
of this infrastructure that we've built
now let's talk about some of the things
that it's important for you to think
about architecting as you build
applications and services on google
cloud and it's important to think about
applications in terms of different types
of applications i often like to think
about particularly in a short session
like this different types of
applications that would be like web
servers and application servers often
being stateless apps and a second set of
applications being databases and very
durable apps places where all of your
data lives and we're going to spend a
little time to talk about each of those
individually
so if we look at the left part of the
slide here the first thing i want to
talk about is load balancing so the
first two load balancing and the gce or
google compute engine auto healing are
really things to first think about when
you're thinking about application
servers and web servers that first
category of applications i mentioned
load balancers essentially redirect
traffic away from unresponsive servers
unresponsive web servers or application
server they may be too busy might be a
software defect there could be a lot of
reasons why a node becomes unresponsive
load balancing essentially will redirect
traffic away from these unresponsive
nodes so your customers and users the
applications get a great experience
there are different options on how you
deploy a load balancer you can deploy it
to essentially give capabilities to span
zones and regions
for more local load balancing there's
also options to essentially do global
load balancing so all of your consumers
and users can come into one single point
and the application may actually be
spread across regions so even full
region outages will be
hidden from your customers they'll be
redirected to surviving you know healthy
nodes
the second layer of defense as chris
mentioned it's good to have multiple
layers of defense for applications of
web servers is to think about auto
healing so in google compute engine this
is our main offering that essentially
offers vms many many applications run in
these vms
and there's a construct that we've
developed called managed instance groups
it's essentially a set of vms that form
an application tier in their environment
they can essentially provide a second
layer of protection and availability and
essentially they will automatically
restart unresponsive nodes so a node may
be too busy it may get somehow locked in
some state that it can't recover from
the load balancer will shift traffic
away from it and then the gc auto
healing will come in to essentially
restart those nodes so again
further re-healing the system
an important thing to think about as you
start to build these layers of defense
is how they work together and an example
is you essentially want the load
balancer to redirect traffic away from
an unresponsive node before it gets
restarted
so as a perfect example you want the
health checks that are in your load
balancer to be more frequent and
aggressive and reshift traffic away from
unresponsive nodes and then the manage
instance group auto healing feature to
kick in also has health checks to work
slightly slower to actually go in and
restart nodes
that may the system is in some sense is
self-healing or auto healing
the second thing i want to talk about is
more on the stateful application tier
which is why i've talked about cloud sql
and spanner so chris mentioned cloud sql
earlier you could of course run a
database inside of one of our vms many
customers choose to do that but it's
also great to think about managed
database offerings to reduce some of the
toil about setting up and running a
database server and that's really where
cloud sql comes in it's a managed
database service we have
it supports a lot of common databases
mysql you know postgresql sql server
and it has a number of interesting
capabilities that really add value in
the forms of durability and resilience
and high availability
one is using snapshot-based backups um
you can automate it so it takes regular
backups let's say every four hours you
have good uh protection points but you
can also use it in on-demand snapshots
if you're going to do a maintenance task
on your database you know add tables
change the schema etc you could create a
snapshot to create an easy recovery
point
uh the database the managed database
service also has a built-in uh
capability to offer you point in time
recovery for your databases so you have
snapshots and then you can essentially
move the database to a particular point
in time based on the logs that are in
the database so it's a combination of
the managed database service working in
conjunction with snapshots to offer you
a capability to really be specific at
exactly the point where the database is
consistent and you want to restart the
application
it's also great to think about the high
availability capabilities in sql in
cloud sql offering because it offers
failover replicas these are essentially
shadow databases that can be set up
there are options inside the service
that can essentially
run in multiple zones to protect you
from a zone outage uh these zonal things
can use the regional pd offering the
regional persistent disk offering that
chris mentioned so we're synchronously
replicating uh the data for the database
underneath the covers
and then you essentially have a a cloud
sql instance that's ready to go in the
event of a zonal outage
there's also a capability in cloud sql
to essentially do
uh cross region protection this is of
course an asynchronous capability uh but
it can also protect you against full
regional outages so again there's a lot
of power and flexibility in terms of the
offering that cloud sql has in terms of
building in resilience and high
availability
the last thing i wanted to think about
or talk to you about in the database
tier is our spanner offering you know
cloud spanner this is a really powerful
capability
it's highly differentiated it really
comes from technology that google built
to you know scale to the billions of
users we have on our consumer
applications
uh it's a fully managed database service
so it's very easy to use but it's
basically a single cross regional
database
it's active active and read write in
many regions all at the same time and
that's really what makes it unique so it
preserves the value of standard sql
because that's such a common uh
application programming language but it
provides you essentially
in some sense is a you know you can
think about a cross-regional database as
a continent-sized database for you to
operate on so it really allows you to
simplify how you think about building
these systems and it comes with a five
nine availability sla so it's really a
powerful capability uh to have in the
arsenal as you think about how you build
applications on google cloud
now i'd like to turn it over to chris
for the next part
much appreciate brian
so let's switch back to business
continuity the insurance policy the
safety net that we all know we need
this continuity is a pretty expansive
term it can mean a lot of things from
how a cloud architect plans for disaster
production it's false
to uh to how a storage administrator
test backups
you'll notice i mentioned planning and
testing right off the bat
and that's we have a number of features
and services built for business
continuity purposes features like being
able to export a copy of your database
to our object storage for a long-term
bible for example
but business continuity is about being
absolutely certain that the data will be
available when the auditor calls
that's why the human element of planning
and testing is so important here
as the saying goes an amateur takes a
backup the professional tests that it
can be restored
so when we dial into a couple services
two interesting ones that i find
differentiated are our multi-region
storage and our orchestrated backup
they play different roles in our
business continuity package
multi-region storage can mean keeping
data in our object storage we'll keep
two copies of the data in two different
regions on a continent available in case
of original failure at semester
this also underpins some of our other
offerings makes it possible for example
for our customers to restore snapshots
stored in north america
to different north american regions
without having to create a handful of
copies across the continent and wait for
them to be replicated one after another
and on the orchestrated backup side
we recently acquired actifio
a proven backup vendor
that sells actifio go a backup is a
service offering built on google cloud
actifio go
can protect google compute engine vms if
you're building in the cloud
or if you're lifting and shifting
relational databases into google
google vms and you need application
consistent agent-based backups
similar to what you have on pram
activio go can deliver the same
functionality to you
allowing you to back up your newly
migrated database workloads as
frequently as every 15 minutes
of all that data can be stored in
multiple
object storage buckets in different
regions and classes
and can be restored directly from object
storage
which means lower long-term storage
costs for customers with severe data
retention requirements and easier
discussions with your internal
compliance counterparts when you test
that a backup is available for example
without the need to
complicate restores or move data around
to different block storage options
these are just two of our features that
we've created to make business
continuity easier for you to plan
and to test
so that you and your team can achieve
those goals around resiliency and high
availability
if you'd like to learn more we've
included a couple of links to some
interesting content
on disaster recovery high availability
and resilience
in the bottom right there's a link to
achieving resiliency
and high availability in cloud sql
it's a video from last year's next and
it covers a lot of the topics we've
discussed here as they apply to that
managed database service
just above that we have a dr planning
guide for gce
for those of you running staple
workloads and google cloud vms we think
you'll find that useful to help you plan
for your dr requirements
over on the left we have a few
sessions at next that we think you'll
find relevant
we've included their titles
and the shorthand may
name with numbers so you can find those
in the catalog
i want to thank brian for co-presenting
with me and i thank all of you for
attending our session